هذا ليس iPhone X ، لكن من المحتوم إلى حد
كبير أن يسميه الناس
أن X هو في الواقع 10 و 10
هو أكبر تجديد لجهاز iPhone منذ
أكثر من ثلاث سنوات أولاً ، دعنا
نتحدث عن تلك الشاشة الآن قامت Apple
بتوسيعها  تقريبًا من الحافة إلى الحافة ، لذا
فهي أطول شاشة iPhone حتى الآن ولكنها
ليست بنفس عرض هواتفهم ذات الحجم الزائد ،
ولكن للحصول على تلك الشاشة الكبيرة ،
كان عليهم التخلص من زر الصفحة الرئيسية ، لذا
بدلاً من الضغط على هذه الدائرة المألوفة ،
يمكنك الآن التمرير لأعلى من  الجزء السفلي
للرجوع إلى جميع تطبيقاتك في
الموضوع هو العقدة ، إنه القسم الوحيد الذي
لم تتمكن Apple من ملء الشاشة ، حيث يحتوي
على نظام كاميرا جديد يتيح التعرف على الوجه ،
لذا بدلاً من إلغاء قفل الهاتف
ببصمة إصبعك ، يمكنك مسح وجهك فعليًا
تهدف إلى فتح الهاتف من
أجلك وإبعاد أي شخص آخر ،
تقول Apple إن التكنولوجيا مصممة
لمنع الانتحال عن طريق الصور أو الأقنعة
وأنها لن تفتح إلا إذا كنت
تنظر إلى الكاميرا وعيناك
مفتوحتان  لذلك قررنا أن نختبرها حقًا
مع توأمان متطابقين Pippa و
Zahra ، حسنًا يا رفاق ، سنقوم
أولاً بتعيينه على Pippa وجهك
يجب أن تذهب في دائرة ، ثم
سنغلقه الآن هذا هو الاختبار  آسف ، دعنا
نرى ما إذا كنت تفعل ذلك ، لذا عليك فقط إلقاء نظرة على
أوه ، لقد أغلقته بأي شكل من الأشكال ، لقد فهمت الأمر جيدًا يا رفاق ،
لذلك خدعنا النظام جيدًا
لنكن واقعيين ، أعني سيناريو لتوأم شرير
يحاول اختراق هاتفك ، من
المستبعد جدًا  حسنًا ، شكرًا
يا رفاق ، تتيح لك الكاميرا الأمامية المحسّنة
أيضًا التقاط صور سيلفي فنية مع
خلفيات غير واضحة وإرسال رموز
تعبيرية تحاكي نظام الكاميرا الذي
يتتبع العضلات في وجهك
وينشطها حتى تتمكن من إضاعة الكثير من
الوقت في القيام بأشياء مثل  هذا الجزء الخلفي
من الهاتف الآن زجاجي وهذا يعني أنه
يمكنك الشحن لاسلكيًا ولكنه
أيضًا مكان آخر لتحطيمه ، ولكن بالنسبة للعديد
من التغييرات الأكثر أهمية ،
فإن سعر iPhone 10 هو سعره الذي سيكلفك
تسعمائة وتسع وتسعين دولارًا ، لذا
يجب  يمكنك شرائه جيدًا إذا كان بإمكانك العيش
بدون أشياء مثل الشاشة الجديدة أو
الكاميرا الأمامية الفاخرة وجميع
الأجراس والصفارات الأخرى ، فإن iPhone 8
سريع بنفس السرعة وأقل بمقدار 300 دولار ولكن بعد
بضع ساعات مع iPhone 10 ، أشعر نوعًا ما
بالخيال